so what are the ramifications of this
political showdown joining us now is RNC
chairwoman Rhonda McDaniel and Fox News
political analyst Giano Caldwell thank
you both for joining us here Arana I
want to start with you because the
messaging from the Democrats has been
about abolishing ice about open borders
about supporting sanctuary cities not
building the wall how did what how in
the world do they have a winning message
with the American people well I
they don't Jason and I think as the
American people learned that asylum
claims are up seventeen hundred percent
over the past eight years when they
learned that 12,000 kids have come here
unaccompanied and their being in held in
the care of HHS because they're they're
coming without their parents to try and
get into this country when they hear all
the things that are happening that there
are 800,000 cases right now pending in
our courts for these asylum claims they
go this is a crisis this is ridiculous
the president is coming to the table
with solutions very reasonable
common-sense solutions and the Democrats
refuse to fix the problem this is owned
by the Democrats and the American people
the more they learn about this are going
to recognize that the Democrats are not
doing right by our country or by the
people trying to come into this country
we need to fix our immigration problem
now Giano I I have never seen a
political party succeed by being anti
federal worker by attacking the 20,000
plus Border Patrol agents about saying
they want to abolish ice about they do
all of these things what is their
message how do you see this playing out
you know it's interesting I was just
talking about this on my Instagram
account and I can tell you the reason
why they do this is because they feel
that the hey the border security folks
may not be voting for them they support
President Trump so when you think about
the fact that in 2006 Barack Obama
himself sent us senator said that we
needed a secure fencing and we he voted
for the secure fencing Act people like
Hillary Clinton Joe Biden Chuck Schumer
they all supported it and now they're
against it certainly because President
Trump has proposed it in
addition to this Sebastien Gorka
mentioned something in the last segment
that was very important there are a
number of criminals that are certainly
trying to get in not all but certainly
there are some if we look back in 2017
ice out of the most of the folks that
they put in seventy four percent of
those folks had past criminal
convictions for things as serious as
possessing or selling drugs these are
the hardcore drugs so when you think
about these facts these very irrefutable
facts how could they not want to protect
our country only because they believe
that they can collate collate some of
these votes to protect their party and
stay in power now Ron I think part of
the messaging actually should be let's
do what the Border Patrol wants to do I
mean we have a lot of these political
pundits we have these members of
Congress had never been down to the
border I was in Congress or eight half
years I went to the border multiple
times riding ATVs chasing guys that had
drugs that we confiscated all these
types of things but most of the members
have never ever been there why has the
the Republicans why haven't they shifted
the focus to the Border Patrol that
people actually put their lives on the
line every day and focus on what they
want because they do want the wall well
they're also the experts they're dealing
with this every day they're on the front
lines you know if you go to your doctor
and they say here you need to take this
medicine we see this all the time you do
it right the ice agents the CBP is the
CBP they're coming and they're saying we
need help we have a crisis we have drugs
coming across the border we have an
influx of these caravans coming we
cannot maintain at the current state and
the Democrats have never listened to ice
and CBP they voted again for sanctuary
cities they voted against Kate's law
when if the Democrats ever supported our
men and women serving at the border and
it's just shameful and Chuck Schumer
owns this a hundred percent Nancy Pelosi
owns this a hundred percent Republicans
and the president are fixing the problem
Democrats come to the table do your job
we need to fix our immigration system
now Giano the the Democrats they have
said all along hey we're for border
security but have you seen them define
what they're supposed support
of border security actually is what is
it no and they probably don't know they
won't have an answer because they have
no interest in finding the answer and
here's why they realized that about 20
45 that there there's going to be a
minority white voter right so we're
talking about there will no longer be
over fifty percent white that's why
they've abandoned the white
working-class that's why they abandoned
the black community a long time ago
because they would like to support any
mirror that there's going to support
these newer aged new generation Hispanic
individuals who will be more likely to
be Democratic voters and that's what
this comes down to they want to continue
to at least assess the power and
continue to climb up the ladder they
have no interest in protecting in our
country they want to protect their power
base and that's what I believe this
comes down to so real quickly for each
of you how does this partial shutdown of
the government how does this actually
come to an end
Ronna well I think the president's going
to hold firm listen this is a president
who came to Washington and said enough
of business as usual he took on Isis
he's taken on deregulation he's taken on
trade deals he's lower taxes and he has
said the immigration problem is is a
crisis we're gonna solve it and he is
not going to blink and Democrats need to
come to the table and fix this problem
it's their job and the American people
the more they learn about what's
happening at our border are going to
support the president in this issue
gianna real quickly the president is
fighting the establishment not only
there in Washington DC but also the
media as well how do you see this
shutdown played out well certainly is
gonna is going to take Democrats coming
to the table do they have any incentive
to come to the table like Rush Limbaugh
said not into January 3rd they have no
incentive so they want to make a plough
a power play here but if the individuals
that these coalition groups continue to
put the pressure on the Democrats we
continue to make the case and I like
what congressman Duffy said if President
Trump gets in front of the cameras and
does and doesn't address to the country
stating the very importance of this we
could see some movement and certainly
some changes Rana and Giano thank you
very much and I think you're right I
think Shawn Duffy's comments were
spot-on